-Our first guest is
an Oscar-nominated,
Golden Globe,
and Emmy-winning actress
whose blockbuster films include
"Basic Instinct," "Casino."
She stars in the new
television series, "Ratched,"
which premieres this Friday
on Netflix.
It is a pleasure to welcome
the one and only Sharon Stone.
-Hey!
-Hi!
Oh, you're the best.
-Hi, son.
-Ha! I love it!
I'm totally gonna bring that up.
Oh, my God, I love you.
How are you doing?
How is --
-I am okay.
How are you?
Where are you?
-We're in the studio.
And I appreciate you coming on,
because I know you're
in quarantine in L.A.,
and it's a very scary time
with everything going on.
-We have to be happy
in the face of disaster.
It's all we have.
-Yeah.
-Our state is burning down.
Two states over is burning down.
We have no assistance.
It's -- I've never --
I just don't even know.
So, yesterday --
I was just in tears yesterday
'cause we had a fire.
We're in a cul-de-sac street,
and we had a fire
in our abutting street,
a house burning down.
And I had to -- you know,
I had thermoses, water bottles.
"Kids, you have to pack
a go bag."
And, you know,
we didn't have to leave,
but I walked through the house
and did that after
I got the kids in bed,
look at saying goodbye to,
you know,
everything we've put
our lives into making
for our families and just say
goodbye to everything
in a calm way by myself.
Like, we're just gonna
get in the car
with the clothes on our back.
Everybody knew they could take
one bag and that's it,
because we live
in this cul-de-sac,
and if we have to go,
we just have to go.
And we had to make
these decisions,
and I had to have this talk
with my boys, like,
"Put your computer
and one pair of shoes,
couple pairs of jeans
and T-shirts and a sweater,
and we're gonna go.
And there isn't
any sentimentality.
We're leaving everything.
Let's go.
And we have to be ready,
because there's not gonna --
Make sure the cars
all have gas, and that's it.
And this isn't an exaggeration
when you have three states --
600 fires in our own state.
-I can't even imagine.
I have friends in L.A.,
and they were just saying
it's just bizarre.
And, like, the --
You can't go outside because --
-It's raining ash
even in the house.
-Sharon, this is just --
-This is what we're breathing.
-Ugh. I want to get to some
happier things to talk about.
-[ Laughing ]
-If you don't mind.
-You want to talk about
my monkey?
-I do. I want to talk about
your monkey.
Your co-star is a monkey.
I want to get to that.
First, I just want to say, and I
always bring this up to you.
We were in a movie together,
and you were cast as my mom.
As my mother.
-As your mommy.
-In flashbacks.
Clearly, flashbacks.
I wasn't in a scene with you,
but it was a kid and you were --
And my mother, when she found
out that you were cast
to play my mom,
she was like, "Finally!
Finally, some accurate casting.
I look exactly
like Sharon Stone."
And I was like --
She told everybody.
People didn't even
have to bring it up.
She's like,
"You know who's playing me?"
And I go, "Yeah, Mom,
stop telling everyone this."
You were so nice to me
and so great.
I loved being around you.
And you know what I loved, too?
Is that you're real.
You are exactly who you
read about in the magazines.
-Some of it.
-Just as gorgeous in person.
Yeah, some of it.
No, I mean the good stuff.
I want to talk about "Ratched,"
because when I heard the --
-It's so good?
-You are getting rave reviews,
and congrats,
and you deserve it.
I was like, Ryan Murphy,
Nurse Ratched, what is he --
-Sarah Paulson.
I go, "What are you cooking up?
Sharon Stone?"
-The wonderful Sarah Paulson...
-It's like the --
-...Judy Davis, Cynthia Nixon,
Amanda Plummer.
Are you kidding?
-How --
-I gotta get Ryan Murphy
on the show,
because I love
everything he does.
He is so --
He has such a great vision.
Yeah, exactly.
And I heard that he wrote
this part for you,
which is kind of funny.
-I'm not sure.
You know, after I went through
the majority of the press junket
and people kept saying,
"He wrote this part for you,"
and I was like, "Yeah."
And it was
a little nerve-racking,
and it was a little this,"
and then,
when we finished the junket,
I was like,
"I'm not sure how if I should --
How should I feel about that he
wrote that part for me?"
-"Is this a compliment?"
-I back here going...
-[ Laughing ]
Because you really go for it.
-"He wrote that part for me."
-No, I think he just knows
that you could get there
as an actor.
And man, oh, man.
-I can play super nuts
better than anybody.
-What I've seen is, like --
I go, "Oh, my gosh. Of course."
I mean, you just nail it.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here is Sharon Stone
in "Ratched," on Netflix.
With Corey Stoll.
-Take a look.
-I can't rest
until I know he's dead.
-Well, I gotta say,
for a quarter million dollars,
I'm confident
I can make that happen.
-Hmm.
I want you to decapitate him.
Once his head is removed,
I want you to bring it to me.
Of course there'll be
logistics involved,
and discretion
is extremely paramount.
But, of course, you know that.
♪♪
I want to give his head
to my son
as a gift for his 21st birthday.
♪♪
-Congrats on "Ratched,"
and I'm so happy to talk to you,
hopefully next time in person.
Sharon Stone, everybody.
"Ratched" premieres
this Friday on Netflix.